was Dublin oh we can we can we can rant
about Ryanair a little bit is it about
the airline I mean like I cuz we don't
let's not like it's a United or American
that like everyone else [ __ ] yeah we
got to deal with the [ __ ] all the time I
mean yeah ya know like Ryanair is I
don't know that's what I said earlier
special its the Honda Civic of [ __ ]
yeah
airfare that [ __ ] is bad dude my dude
the main the main gripe besides the 90
degree seat so you can recline it's the
[ __ ] yellow oh it's crazy
why yeah crazy they've painted the whole
interior of the plane or like all of the
accent points bright taxicab yellow
which is the worst [ __ ] color and
everyone knows that [ __ ] is all you
associate that with his stress and and
and and congestion and like you know I'm
saying I felt like I was sitting in a
[ __ ] daycare the whole time yeah
exactly and all the red cabins are
painted with the that yellow but then it
goes gradient to beige yeah which is the
worst it's [ __ ] revolting and it's oh
and also the color that I in my opinion
like makes like you know influences or I
guess like encourages anxiety the most
yeah I mean I think the part that
encourages anxiety is the glaring laid
out instructions of what to do if the
planes on fire or if the plane is yeah
in the water yeah why the [ __ ] right
below the advertisement for the app to
order drinks which you can't download
because there's no [ __ ] Wi-Fi on the
plane so what is that he's a tease all I
was doing it was the image of this guy
crawling on the ground there plants on
fire that's what I'm looking for two
[ __ ] hours cuz there's no Wi-Fi
there's no TV this is [ __ ] my knees
hit you know you know we're not the
tallest dudes in the world that's how
you know it's bad yeah knees hating the
[ __ ] seat in front of us the whole
time by the way just yeah does you guys
understand like the placard you get with
the safety instructions that [ __ ] was
just a big sticker on yellow plastic
which is about half a foot in front of
your
because that's where the seat is right
here straddle the seat that's in front
of you it's right between your legs and
everyone's straddling and the drink cart
comes through and it [ __ ] hits your
legs sorry let me just you're able to
play footsie with the person in front of
you like if you stick with put out you
can feel their [ __ ] heels and the
funniest part which I I didn't even
think about this your best ruining for
good is yeah is Chris said and then the
the armrests are tilted down a little
bit so if you like oh yeah fall asleep
on your hand like this you slowly slide
forward until you wake up and it's like
that's not even a like that's not even
like an ergonomic thing that's did you
do that to [ __ ] with they do that to
make it more miserable looking the yeah
that everything about that is like the
move the next movie of like the saw
installment should be eight people on a
Ryanair air flight and then it's just be
which one jumps out last may be infinite
fuel yeah I put you on a ride air flight
and it'll be in the sky until you're all
gone there's another plane that is
flying close to it and refueling it
every 12 hours
so you can't get it all Neverland you
just can't [ __ ] sleep
and it's a full airplane there's a full
airplane fill the people yeah yeah
there's like all the seats like you you
have the seat that's assigned to you and
the rest of them are just like they have
spikes yeah
like you'll just go through your back
yeah so you just tuck in your Chevrolet
down yeah never rest your arms on
anything that's not sliding forward you
can never get a drink because you can't
download the [ __ ] app yeah that's it
but there's but there's a flight
attendant yeah and they just won't come
over yeah cuz you need the app yeah did
you want a drink yeah you need the app
to get a drink dude Kelsey goes before
me
to check-in hmm she scans her boarding
pass it's all good she's got a giant
carry-on suitcase
yeah and a giant backpack there I go
right behind her same woman I scan my
boarding
and she looks at my two bags and goes oh
did you pay for one of these to be
carried on and I'm like no what do you
what do you mean and she was like all
you have to have to pay to get Tyrion's
and I'm looking at Kelsey and so she may
be paid 30 whatever 30 euro and I
checked all my electronics Ryan there's
just a shitty club a hole of nos 34 guys
it's ladies night tonight ladies day
yeah but you know if you wanted you want
to pop in with her is 30 bucks bro
flip-flops I got six girls with me
though all right yeah yeah yeah you guys
are good you'll get their priority yeah
yeah are you cool yeah you cool put him
near the front and then people then a
group of guys sitting in rows one and
two they all get booted to the back as a
bunch of girls get on the plane and
they're like yo what the [ __ ] dude we
paid for this table sorry man no we paid
for this table dude I know but it's Waco
sorry about your boy sir you guys are
out so we paid 400 bucks for the table
do yeah okay what the [ __ ] that's our
bottle that's our but why is she
drinking our bottle do we paid for this
[ __ ] like KLM is like a it's like a
high-class nightclub yeah that's like
lights just like hide what we're talking
about yeah we're talking about like
North Hollywood you know or no like even
even what's like a shitty club that we
want to mmm like middle America yeah
anything oh the one where we saw a
[ __ ] lay yeah yeah yeah was that I
can remember West Virginia oh [ __ ]
you